we are prisoners on earth the universe
taunts us by showing us all the places
we can't ever visit however if our
species wants to have a long-term future
we have to escape our prison but what's
keeping us here in the first place
turns out we owe the universe a debt
that is 4.5 billion years old everything
with mass in the universe attracts every
other thing with mass we call this
phenomenon gravity the closer you are to
a big chunk of mass the stronger the
attraction or the more you're pulled in
this effect traps us on earth we can
imagine this as being prisoners in a
gravity prison or a gravity well it's
not a literal wealth but a handy concept
to understand how this works being in a
gravity prison means that you Oh gravity
energy but how can you Oh energy because
in our universe things don't want to
change their speed or direction to
convince them to move you have to expend
energy billions of years ago the
gravitational attraction of trillions of
trillions of dust particles orbiting our
Sun pulled them together until they
formed a planet this process used energy
and created the gravity well we're now a
part of the deeper you are inside a
gravity well the more energy you Oh
gravity if you don't find a way to get
enough energy you're not able to leave
no matter what you do because your atoms
were once part of the dust that the
universe expended energy on to get to
this place okay hmm
let's summarize all of that again
objects in the universe don't like to
move you have to convince them to do so
with energy gravity used energy to
convince the parts that make up our
planet to move to get
this created a gravity prison in the
process trapping us to escape it we need
to repay it with energy okay how do we
do that to get into space we need to go
through a complicated process of
exchanging energy for this purpose we
build a negative potential energy
repaying machines known by their more
boring name Rockets Rockets work by
using some of the most energetic
chemical reactions humans know about to
basically explode fuel in a controlled
way this converts chemical energy into
kinetic energy the exhaust of the
reaction is directed outwards and pushes
the rocket away from Earth by expending
a lot of energy we are increasing our
gravitational potential energy which is
a complicated way to say that we're
paying back our energy depth to gravity
but it's actually a lot trickier than
that when you burn fuel to get into
orbit you lose lots of energy to heat
the exhaust and atmospheric drag so you
actually need much more and you can't
just part a huge amount of radius
plosive dangerous for your close to your
payload and detonate it
you need a controlled burn which is
complicated and makes your rocket very
heavy which means it has more mass the
more mass something has the more energy
you need to convince it to move so you
need more fuel to lift up your rocket
but if you need more fuel that means you
need more rocket to carry that fuel but
this makes your rocket heavier thus
requiring more fuel which requires more
rocket to carry that new fuel and so on
at the end of this madness you need
closer to a hundred times the weight of
your payload to launch arianna six for
example the European rocket will wait
800 tonnes and should be able to
transport 10 tonnes into geostationary
transfer orbit or 20 tonnes into medium
Earth orbit but a rocket can only
produce so much thrust so there's a
maximum weight after which it just won't
take off
if you add too much weight it won't lift
off so you can't just build bigger and
bigger fuel tanks this is the tyranny of
the rocket equation and it means space
flight will never become easy but wait
it gets worse
getting to space is still not good
enough you're still inside the gravity
prison at the edge of space and we'll
crash back to earth
staying in space is much harder than
getting there to get to a stable
position where it can stay for a while
the rocket has to reach low-earth orbit
to do this you need a lot of kinetic
energy which means going extremely fast
at an altitude of about 100 kilometers
this is 8 km/s 28,000 kilometers per
hour fast enough to travel around Earth
in 90 minutes
here we can use a trick instead of
flying straight up we can go sideways
earth is a sphere so if you're going
sideways fast enough even though you're
falling towards Earth the ground will
curve away beneath you so as long as
you're above the atmosphere about 100
kilometres up you'll be able to stay up
there in orbit this is what the ISS does
falling around Earth expending energy
from time to time to stay fast enough if
we look at orbits in scale we see that
near Earth orbit is laughably close to
Earth to deploy for example satellites
or leave for other planets requires
another round of energy debt repayment
getting to orbit is the most difficult
part of spaceflight for us right now for
example if we want to send a rocket to
Mars half the energy is necessary just
to get into orbit and the other half for
the 55 million kilometres to Mars
therefore to be as effective as possible
Rockets aren't built in one giant piece
instead we use multistage rockets you
don't need to carry an empty fuel tank
so Rockets drop it Rockets today shed
their boosters and main stage as they
ascend with each successive stage being
its own fully
contain rocket complete with its own
engine and fuel okay so this is why
getting to space is heart if you feel
all of this seems really complicated
don't worry
it's literally rocket science this video
was made possible in part by a
sponsorship by Airbus Safran launches
and arianna space who are getting their
new ariane a six rocket ready to launch
into space in 2020 you can learn more
about the rocket here and as always if
you like what we do please consider
supporting us on patreon comm it really
helps us out a lot if you're craving
more space stuff now here's a playlist
for you
[Music]